yes ladies and gentlemen no welcome
no to michel foucault the great
french structure alliston to be more
precise post-structuralism foucault is
undoubtedly one of the most radical and, as
you will see, provocative
ssten thinkers of the 20th century
he may not have founded his own school of thought
or school, but he does belong
those philosophers whose impact
has not diminished after their death but
rather increased
that is very gratifying on the one hand
because a core idea
has remained alive sir yes you will see in a moment it
has become much more explosive
but on the other hand it is also a bit
worrying because his core idea is
also something very worrying that has i
brought you here right
away man disappears like on the
seashore a face in the sand
man will disappear and as a
14-year-old professor at the collège
de france that is the elite university
in paris sparkles then  actually
be  explains nothing less to an astonished student
than just the end of
man by
that he does not mean that the species will
die out, for example due to a
nuclear attack  actually make us
understand that humans as we
know them will die out as self-determined, lustfully
active beings and this
process begins as early as the 17th 18th
century, this is a
key time for ecology because that’s when
science and enlightenment and
the new sciences succeeded for the first time
to define the human being precisely he is
no longer God's creature but
biology psychology psychiatry
criminology all
look at the human being as an object and for the first
time he is defined from what is normal and
abnormal what is healthy what is mentally
ill or even what that is  properly
what the criminal and these definitions
say about courses extremely consequential because
in this phase it
was actually tried for the first time in one with a huge
effort to create hospices and to lock away
all the insane as was said
at the time at the same time there were huge large
prisons in the 17 18
century because now  could just be
defined yes is crazy and we
not that's why foucault says the madman
can't not be for himself they weren't
but only in the eyes of a third
person who alone is
able to distinguish reason from reason
and just like it is now suddenly
this  crazy houses there were then in the
eighteenth century large
prisons were built for tens of thousands of
them sat
before that there were of course already
kiaka in the knights' castles in the palaces
individual hackers there was also the
so-called pillory i.e. a wooden pole
on the market square where one could sometimes be
seen  was asked
but they were individual  those in the
dungeons were the mass prisons
are so happy an
achievement of modernity because tens of thousands of places were now
needed, the english
social philosopher and lawyer jeremy band planned
a completely new type of prison on the
drawing board and invented it, which was then also
built, the so-called panopticon
prison i  I brought him one once so
that you can get an impression that it was actually built is
now his ruins from cuba
but you can already see the principle of
this panopticon prison here the
Werthers could go underground into this
tower and look out of the tower through the
slits
and all the prisoners  take a
look at a pan greek everything is
optical it is an all-seeing
look and the advantage now was that the
value was there or not and
even if he could of course
never look at the whole numbers you
have the around
but  the mere fact that the
prisoners think  n they must be able to be in
sight is enough that they feel seen
and thereby they do something they
automatically adjust their behavior
accordingly as if they were just being
seen there is a kind of
self-discipline in
anticipatory obedience and that,
ladies and gentlemen, is what foucault says  is
the principle of our modern coercive
society we all take a look at
ourselves and practice anticipatory
obedience and take a close
look look at us if you are right you
are all sitting in
one of these cells too of course right
now now no you will see in a moment  why
the one optical scheme is
destined to spread in the social
body to become a
generalized structure
so that one optical china has become
over time the generalized
structure of our whole
society what does he mean by that
maybe here is an example not
bad how that  man optical
scheme  expanded in civilization it
is used to improve convicts but
also to instruct students to
monitor the insane to
supervise
workers to create jobs for idlers so
you know the students were then
first after the optical
prison was invented also
lined up in rows of benches stand under  the
panopticon view of the teacher and the
good conduct is assessed as with the
convicts by means of a pin,
behaving grades by means of censorship demotions
et cetera and you have just
like the convicts between two
ring tones schoolyard walk
but yes and then the scheme is
described completely naturally in
detail in his bestseller  here
roads and monitor
then this topic is of course also transferred
to the world of work there are
glass cases where the previously mentioned
factory workers take a look
but something completely different is much more
important for him the glitch
optical sight  which is expanding and
i would like to show you how explosive
this idea actually is in
china there are currently several
major optical projects
going wrong pilot projects one of which is called
honest shanghai shanghai is
now completely monitored by cameras and
the residents receive points
according to a point system if they
If you go through red at the traffic light or throw away a paper cup
, it will be recorded and evaluated
with your face ID at the moment
and you will receive a
deduction of points
. If you work together,
a two-digit number of
offices will work together and this will run into the
central computer when you receive an invoice
if you pay too late if you had a tax
dishonesty if you submit the tax
too late or if you watch
a video with pornographic
content on the internet there will be deductions immediately
and anyone who has less than 1000 points is considered a
bad person now of
course the shanghai residents try from the
start  to do everything exactly and properly
so as not
to become a bad person in the first place that is what
you deserve optical scheme but unfortunately we do
n't even have to look to china
in germany too we have more and more a
few optical systems which as
foucault said literally in the
social body  spread in
hesse there is a pilot project running,
the police officers have cameras with sound on their
uniforms clearly visible and as a result,
after the first
evaluation, the abuse of the
officers has actually decreased they are no
longer insulted, no longer spat at,
no longer attacked and the
officers also behave  absolutely
exemplary towards the citizens because
everything is documented and recorded
you understand the political view
that being seen is everywhere
you can already see from these two
small examples how explosive his
thesis is that the leg optical
system spreads throughout the entire social
body  t ok
so today we will deal with madness and
society where he shows how for the first time
the definition of madness and
normality arise with surveillance and
punishment and of course what is also extremely
important with his philosophical
capital the order of things and
therein again presented a
provocative  namely the
thesis that we all here in the room
think that we know certain things for
sure yes and everyone thinks they have
a truth but there is no
truth says fokko in
reality we are all externally controlled by what we think
and say from someone
behind  standing deeper truth'
production which we often don't even see
through and he formulates that here
in the order of things
so you will still find out today why you think the way you think and
why you say what you say fine
and because we are controlled  are
productions of knowledge behind it
and they determine our discourses there
e i took part in another example
the discourse is the totality of
forced or rather compelling
meanings that permeate the social conditions
so it is not that we freely
contribute something to the discourse but they
are forced to contribute to the discourse and
there he has e.g. you know each and every one  time
has its own truth production
every society has its own
order of truth yes and a
general policy of truth and
this is how the order of
things arises and this order of truth
comes from deeper down,
for example behind antiquity
was the deep lies the truth'
production  the slaves see the whole thing
naturally and belong to every good
household and even plato
aristoteles didn't dare
to contradict this truth' production
yes not only that
they didn't dare it didn't even occur to them
because they were only a product of this
truth'  production goods and you can
so photo ze  shows us that basically even
more clearly in this example
the discourses on mental illness don’t tell us
what the subject is but only
what is within a certain
, completely special truth
is the discourses on mental illness
when we talk about mental illness
don’t tell us what  the mentally ill
really is but only what is the
truth game out of which we
talk about the mentally ill when a
north american indian
they believed that the confused
were touched by the spirit of manitues and the
medicine if there then led a
discourse what and the confused  what
kind of message manitu might want to send us about the confused person
if in the middle ages you have the
most precise ones so you thought the
mentally confused people were possessed by the devil
and the exorcists
tried to exorcise the devil again
and nowadays they are conducting
a discourse there  whether the confused
neuro  is a tic or psychotic and
try to lead him through various symptoms
for a bundle of symptoms of
specific
pathological diseases and to
treat him but both from the
Indians from the exorcists and the
psychiatrists we do not really
know about the object but we learn
the basis of the truth game  on
which those who are sitting up
talking about mental illness and from
ko now says that it is of the greatest importance for us right now
that we know
no which deeper truth'
productions our knowledge is
based on, we too today are victims of
a deeper truth' production like
you  even more responsible and they
then also call this positive there are positives
that determine us without us noticing it that's
why i brought you
the positives of the market the
positive is a key term in the
photo that i also
want to introduce to you
that means we have  a lot to
do  rt off with madness and society
foucault says madness is
not to be found in the natural state of course not
in the real state in the natural state there is no
madness first it has to be defined
and in this book that is a much-
respected doctoral thesis 500 pages it has
already become well-known because
he did something very exciting
he looked at how the individual
societies in the different
epochs dealt with madness
what did they define as their crazy and
insane and from this
results what was reasonable in the respective
epoch and society
and there  makes the whole
crack he basically describes a
history of occidental reason
from the perspective of madness so
you see it was an unconventional
thinker and that's why madness is
of course always just what it is defined as at
the respective time here
you can see it too  madness is total
lack of reason that man  on the
background of the structures of the
reasonable perceives that was
not always the case
in the renaissance, for example
, madness was not yet a total
lack of reason that was taboo and that
was suppressed and had to be fought
on the contrary this world from the beginning
of the 17th century is on  strange
way hospitable to
madness yes, for example, princes
and higher nobles but only the higher
ones had their own farm shop that made sure that madness was in the castle
i.e. it was allowed to be
unconventional,
could insult, was allowed to
say crazy things and collect them and
hang them together  the court jester was happy, yes
, the true freedom and he also
often played an
important role in the theater because
madness was a bit part of the
culture and that's why foucault says madness
fascinated people on all sides
that's also shown by
the works of  paint like bow  Grünewald
or ironimus bosch and
i was brought something for you that
i can see quite well yes you look here like
a monster well he has many monsters of
the bosch subscriptions with bird
heads fish heads or other animal
heads eat people alive
and you  also see how
crows or feels come out of the anus so come and
here one is eaten someone is
impaled often toads sit on
genitals so yes
let the imagination run free and very
often you see heavy and lances stuck in the anus
and so whole  Honestly, these
herbal days from a psychiatric point of view, yes
, I don't want to think about that at all,
but I assume they would see
the multi-perversely regressive para
many as urgently in need
of therapy  belonged to society
and even in the villages one has the
crazy  ckten not locked away there was of
course a lot more to it
then there were a lot of village idiots
but they laughed too and the
children we put
a gun to them with a string but they
were tolerated
yes and that’s what foucault says in the
middle ages and  in the renaissance
, the insane were allowed
to live in the bosom of society, the so-called
village idiot was
fed and cared for by the others and that
changed radically with the decree of 1656 by the
sun king ludwig the fourteenth, who
famously decreed
that he wanted it  no longer and
has decreed that in the future all strays and
also all tramps
will be concentrated in hospices and
imprisoned and, interestingly,
used to do this the leprosy
houses leprosy disappears leprosy
was extinct at the time yes so that’s why
these houses stood empty
leprosy disappears  the lepers
are almost forgotten but the structures
remain  often in the same places
two or three centuries later one can find the
same forms of exclusion in a
striking
resemblance tramps and confused heads
play the role that the leper once
played so the mentally disturbed play the role of the
lepers because they too are out of the middle
of society  be taken be
isolated so that they no longer
infect anyone with their madness
madness was made taboo and is
blocked
and where he also speaks of the
beginning of the great imprisonment of
madness what he regrets the photo yes
and it did for them it did
through the enlightenment  another
change was made, of course, then, of course,
the insane were no longer viewed as possessed by the
devil, but as
mentally ill people who they wanted to heal again
, so the approach was already there, but
says fokko, this new humanistic
view of the mentally ill also has
its own situation  basic situation
being exposed to the compulsion the compulsion
of normality didn't improve much it
didn't get much more humane as you can now
see from the following three little pictures
how nell actually a
progressive psychiatrist
invented the straitjacket in 17 95 if he thought
that the complete fixation calms the mind
yes or  for example,
charles darwin's grandfather invented the erasmus darwin he invented the darwin chair he
could rotate yes english
how it was developed in the charité
then the so-called 3-bet
was i don't know if you can see it exactly
here the accent is on a welt  and
you could use a cable winch to turn that was
extremely fast until 5 6 g had
an effect on the brain all the blood
shot into the brain and the idea behind it
was that the psychiatrists thought well
all these blocked blood and
nerve tracts in the brain just have
to go through bloody ones again  be
appropriate because you laugh ladies and
gentlemen foucault has shown us  that we
are not much further today and treat according to the
same dispositive
in psychiatry today with
electroconvulsive
therapy with electric shocks trying to get these blockages out of the brain yes of course you have to
sign that you
agree with it
so that is not so that therefore
torture can be yes  So you have to
sign that you agree
, but they also try to get the
constipation going
, the medication also has no
other purpose than to stimulate messenger substances in
the brain that have come to a standstill
and get them moving
again, so she doesn’t think like that
a lot has changed even if we now
consider it brutal good and there
has certainly been something new
in this great imprisonment is the
essential and new element that the law no
longer condemns so in
this great imprisonment the
essential new element is that the law no
longer condemns  son  So it's not
just the judge, it's
experts, and scientists are
there and doctors are
psychologists
who decide who gets behind the
walls, so to speak, and who stays outside, and
in the period that follows, hundreds of
different specific mental
illnesses are precisely defined with
symptom pictures  and these exact
definitions of science says soko
has led to the fact that not only
those who disappeared behind the walls
were defined as
mentally ill, but also we
outside the walls define ourselves
as not
having these criteria and therefore being
allowed to be outside so that's why  foucault can
say in a certain sense the
walls of the internment houses enclose the
negative a moral community
so we are the negative those who are
within psychiatry yes a
moral community
reserved for all those who submit to it from the beginning
we  submit to the normalization coercion
that's why we can
stay further out and the pedagogical sentence
that is often said to the children
is reasonable because it says that is
now the motto of our entire
modern society reason is
an enormous force and does not tolerate any
deviation in me the madness  is
now massively taboo and
completely suppressed since the end of the
eighteenth century so foucault
the life of unreason manifests itself
only in the flash of
works like hölderlin's nietzsche or
artus because they are back by their own power to
that gigantic
prisoner so only a few writers
are allowed to stand still  or because they have
their own inner strength, they can withstand this pressure
of normality again and still
articulate the madness and that's why
I'll draw a summary from the book
madness and social animal,
a conclusion
first of all
[music]
has reason over the centuries
as an antidote  ler as a lively
dialogue partner the madness was
always there
but now in the modern age our
reason only leads a monologue and
no longer tolerates deviations
and that leads to an enormous
normalization pressure you all know the
saying just be careful otherwise
the men will get you  in the white
sneakers yes is a bad saying
actually if we wear a nightgown and
the forced normalization is also the subject of
his second work punish and
monitor is perhaps the
most-read work by foucault
hit like a bomb
it already begins quite legendary so
the beginning is  legendary in four pages
without announcing it without explaining
, foucault describes the distribution
of francois tamiya on the market place of
counts in the year 1757 according to the
chronicle of a police officer so me
and that goes over five pages i
have now shortened it a bit but i want to
in  he shouldn't
withhold the enjoyment on the handle  his
nipples, arms, thighs and
calves were to be pinched with red-hot
tongs his right hand was to
hold the knife with which he had committed his father's
murder and
molten
lead was to be poured onto the spots studded with numbers sifting the oil burning pitch
a sheep judge an
executioner  had to start two or
three times and turn and twist
at these numbers then screamed
very loudly without of course blaspheming
despite all this pain hofer from
time to time looked at his head
undauntedly those at later
approached him and the coast gladly that
crucifix and kept saying
sorry sir sorry
the horses gave a strong jerk
and each tugged at one limb
but without success
you had to cut the flesh almost to
the bone the horses
put themselves in the harness and then tore
first their right arm and then the other
los after the 4 were
separated came at
but the simpler one told him
he was dead although i actually
saw how the man moved
as said by kobe writes it in
much more detail but why
doesn't he do it out of voyeurism not out of greed for
sensation but he wants to
punish and monitor us right away  at the beginning
the
nature of the punishment in the earlier epochs before the eyes and
the nature of the punishment was that the perpetrator was inflicted the
torment of the others
multiplied now inflicted himself
so that he atones for it and out of revenge and
at the same time it was always
public  of
course, dividing into four also had the purpose of
deterring the many others who watched on the market
square yes there were
many such drastic types of execution
'take wheels burn decapitate
brand whole series of punishments
against the body the body was always
punished massively and that has now changed
fundamentally  changed in the reconnaissance
we now have a new
knowledge pro  oduction in the reconnaissance
foucault one was disgusted by the
torture series they said
we still have to see the human in criminals
and that is why they were no
longer tortured they were locked up
but what happens now where said now
all punishments are directed against ours
spirit no longer against the body
against the spirit and that with a very
high intensity and because it had now
become necessary
so one now also said that
a prince should no longer arbitrarily
set an example here or there, but
a law regulates how  it took a long time for people to be
locked up and as a result there
were suddenly tens of thousands of
people there who had to be locked up
and beckham, whom i announced
earlier, designed an event in his prison
, yes, the panopticon is a
ring-shaped building so that everything
the individual does is in view  that
value is exposed without being
added yourself, so it is crucial
h  here you can see the building was
completely round in the middle was the
tower where you couldn't see the
werther but the prisoners had to have this
impression the decisive thing is the
pan optical view seeing everything the all-
seeing view the prisoner must never
know if he  is being monitored but
he has to be sure that he can be monitored at any time
,
yes, and then the
prisoners behave of their own accord as if they were being
seen. The
one who is
subject to visibility and knows this takes over
the coercive means of power and plays
them off against themselves  he internally
analyzes the balance of power in
which he plays both roles at the same time
he becomes the principle of his
own submission
that of course saves time and money
nowadays there is camera surveillance and
what has of course changed nowadays
we no longer just
want to lock up we want to resocialize yes
we want says  fokko the locked
up good again  making things easier for the
labor market and of course there are
now a large number of experts in the
forensic departments of psychiatry who
look to see whether he or she relapses or
not and write expert opinions
there are social educators there are
resocialisation helpers etc
but these are also generally seen as
progress foucault makes a contribution
viewed critically
he says normality judges are to
be found everywhere we live in the
society of the judge doctor is that the
judge educators the judge
social worker submits to him everyone
the behavior instead of the
big staged theater as
for example the execution of
françois then yes this distribution
now occurs  many many small
punishments yes and that's why and these
small punishments spread the
compulsion to normality
so you have to imagine the tight
society a thousand small
punishments theater that makes us happy
that we are nowadays in the schools in
the companies in the b  authorities
so millions of people are monitored
from birth certificates to school
to contribution times to
unemployment etc to
death certificates we are recorded and
observed and checked for our
tax honesty on our
traffic behavior et cetera and the
whole
thing no longer requires physical punishment  the
tax officer and hits you if
something is wrong or that is no longer
necessary because he says the power
tends to be physical so no
king or the boat drives me through the
country in a visible golden
carriage and demands the kneeling of his subjects
and the city of togliatti and a
example of a criminal but it
's much worse says fokko we all
submit ourselves to
the entire machinery in advance
and that's why he says this is now a
very central quote from monitor and
punish
we are locked in the wheelwork of
the pan optical machine that  s we
ourselves keep a cog in motion
and i have to
think about it again recently, you know, when you shop on the internet
, it is registered by the optical
machine, you then
immediately get advertising about similar books, or
if you watch a video, it is
registered  so
you are always in the spotlight and of course you are
also a cog if with
every post with every facebook entry
everything you say publicly on the internet
you will of course
become even more transparent so we ourselves are a
cog in the whole thing and contribute to it
is now  just a small example
yes and now he says
the power is going to be physical
and we are connected to a
gear train of the pan optical machine and
now he also has a central
thesis that power with its own generation
is not the power of a few
powerful ones  power is not the
power of a more powerful because
it differs massively
from  for example karl marx and all
under critical theory who say there
are powerful elites let's say the
idea big boya you or the
capitalists who then
oppress and exploit the others with the help of ideology
says no fokko says we
all play along with our anticipatory
obedience we all hold on  the chastisement
theater in the hallway so he talks about the
microphysics of power there is power
in the family too
so he has this idea of the micro
hysics of power and we all take part
n it well
'll summarize the streets again and m
nitor that  the optical model
developed by bentheim in the eighteenth
century has spread
throughout society
and
i can think of just one example because i recently
wanted to look something up at my place they have some
in english on the site where they
do propaganda  pages
have now been shut down by the constitutional
protection durc  h a sabotage
but i wanted to go to this one
page and thought again but be
careful further
if you go to the page then you are
again on some list of people
who go to the us page yes so you
can see it is not something right
there
all right and that's why he can also say that the seamless penalty system that captures and controls every moment
has a dominating and normalizing effect on norms,
yes, we are all part of this
optical system and that has a normalizing and normalizing effect on us
and now of course you can reply to him
yes  the fact that there are also positive
sides to this the police officers are no
longer being mobbed and spat at shanghai every year
shanghai is getting smaller and smaller and
bill gates, for example, already has 19
so you all know that the great
pioneer of the internet and computer
technology already wrote in 1995 in his book
with the  significant title of the way
forward written that through the
digitization  g and the pan optical
machine that crime will not be a
problem in the future, take the example of
monaco in the principality,
all the underground car parks in the
public squares in the streets are now actually monitored
and street crime has dropped to
zero because those with face
IDs look straight away, so we have them
content then get out yes he
brings a second example he says
we would have to be able to
not so many if there were about 12 satellites
then we could equip all seven billion
people and also all wald 8 billion
with a data helmet similar
to gps  from the author and localize
where you are every second that is
not a big effort
yes and of course it is not a real
helmet but i could put my molar in the
tooth and block it in such a way that
you cannot get out yourself
and then if a serious crime is
committed  just check me out
if our doctors can
kill death  set the exact time in the meantime
then you check how it
was yes and then say there is no
more report neither the robber-murderer who
what do we think will be a year now in
white january they had me because they
even know where i am and
then the crime would stop  now he says it
's the case that many people are afraid for
data protection reasons because they
don't always want to be located
and think dictator might be useful
now people should
at least be allowed to voluntarily
keep a data logger book and if
they are accused of him they can
say to the judge with a declaration of consent he can look at the satellite
and then you can see but it
wasn't there yes so you see yes he saw it
positively crazy or and
foucault but warns us very energetically
and said there is no end in sight to this development
modern
man is his own
prison warden and now we come
to the ke  rn thoughts of foucault which he formulated in
his book the order of things in
his main philosophical work
and you will soon
see everything that we here in the room regard as
humanistic
progress modern penal system the
sensitive therapeutic treatment
of the mentally ill etc
the new sciences biology
psychology  Psychiatry, criminology and
also economics, he says, ultimately
only lead to disciplining us even more, better,
exactly,
yes, the enlightenment that
discovered the freedoms also invented the disciplines.
By
that he means that the enlightenment
did indeed demand political freedom,
i.e. that of the Roma  teske but
at the same time the scientists
have always invented new disciplines in the enlightenment
disciplines are
the new sciences biology
psychiatry psychology criminology
also economics he says the economics has made
us even more difficult because we are
now becoming science  actually said that the
free play of forces is the best and
we have to move
within this defined, disciplined scope
and now he says in this book that of
course not only we are the victims of this
discipline but of course also in
earlier times there was an
outstanding one  society shapes the
truth' production and the names
systems it comes from the greek and
means knowledge science he uses
but he goes a bit further because
he says in a culture and at a
certain moment there is always only
one track that defines the conditions
under which any knowledge  so it is
possible the app is eme defines the
basic conditions on which then
every knowledge and every discourse on
ruth we
lead was for example the app is theme of
the renaissance was the representation
the similarity of says the renaissance
team no matter what it
presented has done in  similarities and
representations g  ethought because he
still related everything to the cosmos and
creation, and even people
who, for example, dissected a corpse
and explored the body,
still sorted everything according to similarities to the
big picture, I
quoted foucault himself, which is
a source here
flesh so man his
flesh is a clod his bones
are rocks his veins great rivers
his hair is pale is that me and so
the existence of man is still
seen in the humble expectation of
divine grace and that is of
course in our app is complete
disappeared
and this transition from an old to a
new system draws, for example,
the hero of the novel don quixote very
clearly because don quixote was
quoted first there the focus writes
the hero at the wall is don
quixote who through the sole game
of similarity locks in the
hostels and ladies in the peasant girl
ma deciphered  turned himself into a
prisoner without him knowing it so
the don quixote who had already lived under
capitalism actually in the
modern age of the beginning
liked but still upheld the old systems
from earlier times
who still believed in honesty, virtue,
chivalry, good nature
and  upheld these values and as a result all m
dern peopl
laughed their heads off at him for that
e was just crazy and in th
s book he not only shows us how the syste
s are, by the way, he has three diffe
ent epochs of the track once the r
naissance sixteenth century the c
assic  17 to 18
this questionable time just so this
turning point time when the disciplinary
society has to do something and then our
modernity from the 19th century what are
the three different slopes and he
shows us here not only how the
truth' production changes like videos
but on  the end of the book in the
last sentence comes to its fatal
conclusion  conclusion that i have
shown you before man disappears on the
seashore like a face in the sand is
the last sentence of this book and how
does he get there he says well
as i said it does not mean the extinction of
the species but that we
ourselves  in the structures and in the
knowledge bases that we have
created since the
enlightenment man has tried first during the enlightenment
and also later in the
sciences to prove that we are a
free being we say in comparison
to the animals
but what do they have  found the
scientists they never found our freedom of
decision but
the opposite they only ever
found structures where we cannot
decide
example psychology the end of
man
well that is still important that is
still ahead chance the end of
man is just one of the visible ones
forms of a much more general
dying by that I mean d  en death of the
subject the subject as the origin of the
knowledge of the freedom of language and
history so when man dies
then he does not mean that we
die as a species but he means the death of the
subject that as the origin of the woman
he has under language is active and
we have always considered ourselves to be the
ones who are
completely free about language, but in the
emerging sciences
freedom is sought, but it is
no longer discovered, for example
in psychology, when people started to think about
the human being as a possible object
of knowledge  to research you came across
an unconscious that was completely dominated by drives
and instincts that had
nothing to do with what you had expected from
human freedom and
that's exactly how it works in
biology, so at the beginning you also
looked to see if you could find it  the
control center of freedom
but what came today at the biology house
at the end what did the biolo  gie found
we all know it in biology
the chromosomes carry
all the information that is necessary for the
development of the respective living
being so not only
eye color hair color also certain
character traits even intelligence
claim they are now controlled by the
chromosomes so we lose
ourselves in the structures  and so there
comes the conclusion our days
prove without a doubt the fact
that man is about to
disappear
the death of the man he
formulated here was of course a bang
and this book the order of things
was only published in the first few months in
france  sold 30,000 copies although it has
some abstract passages that are
really difficult and in
the parisian cafés you suddenly no longer have
full tables on the tables
but foucault and the nouvelle
observateur title foucault like
hotcakes and saddle was a big fan
of  foucault di  the two of them fought each other
because he was the great
philosopher of freedom and foucault
said no we are not free the
structures are crucial
and in fact he was
the figurehead of
structuralism throughout europe and he also got a
chair in
1970  at the collège de france of the elite
university of paris just 40
years old
now so young there is the normal i
had been given a chair for the history of
steering systems so it was tailored exactly to him
and that’s why he became the
figurehead of structuralism but
he is actually a
poststructuralism  no real
structural is even if
it looks like that now everyone knows what
structuralism is so it is easily
explained structuralism was invented or put into practice
for the first time by
the french linguist saucen,
a linguist who advocated the thesis
that language is not just
an instrument or  no instrument and
kei  n tool of man is
but vice
versa man is only produced by language
and man is
shaped by language and completely
determined the best way to understand
this thesis is with wittgenstein who once formulated this beautiful sentence
philosophically exactly the
end not the  limits the limits yes
thank you the limits of our
language mean the limits of my world the
limits of our language mean the
limits of my world what do you mean by that
is very simple
try to think beyond language
without words without a sentence
it doesn't work it works  not you
can speak is not possible without
words and sentences anyway i could get up
but it makes no sense so you
understand and you can't think beyond the
borders of the language
so your imagination is also limited by the
language from the cage of the language  and
no one can get out of their structure,
this structure is real  stische
linguistic theory was taken over
by the great ethnologist claude
lévi-strauss who then said that's exactly
how it
is and it's exactly the same with myths too
we don't invent
myths but the myths into which we
rhein are born the mythological
worldviews that determine our  whole
existence said in his main work with
mythological and foucault initially does the
same
and exactly they are right the structure
alliston and i'll show you the
history of your thinking systems the
history euro underlying
truth' productions which you often do
n't even know but which determine your thinking
and  nevertheless where is almost
structural in the end because he says clearly we
are determined by the positive
that controls us without us noticing it but
if we succeed in recognizing and uncovering this positive production of
this deep truth
then we can free ourselves a bit
or get rid of these
structures he says quote
philosophy again is a movement with the
help of which one liberates oneself from what
is considered to be and according to other
rules of the game so well we have to see through the
'truth' production that
is laid out deep down and then
free ourselves from what is waiting for us at the moment
So we have to
recognize this positive and that brings me to the
last big key concept that
I want to bring to you at the end.
This positive important concept in
foucault what is a dispositive first of all
about the concept consists of the word
positive and the prefix dispositive
means simple  determinable
and that this means the exclusion
so if you
determine a positive blood group in someone, for example,
then he has such and such a blood group and
at the same time you rule out
that another blood group has the
term dispositive comes from the
French military system there there is
attack the positive and  defensive
the positive an attack dis  positive,
for example, is the coordinated
planning for the use of the weapon branches
infantry aircraft air force tanks
artillery and prescribes what the
individual branch of arms has to do exactly
and what it absolutely has to
refrain from dispositive yes so an
attack dispositive the example of
the tanks does not say too far in advance
are allowed to experience because otherwise you will lose the
supply
what is the positive and before
not that now to the whole of
society and says this positive
writing what society or
areas of society have to do and not
to do and it
then defines what i  under
dispositiv attempts to fix attempts is
an ensemble that is said as well as
encompasses
what is said what does it mean that is now said and is
announced and why is it an
ensemble an ensemble it is white often
consists of completely different elements
understand the compulsion to
normalize the  consists of volume
one  t a prison from psychiatry
made up of very different elements which,
however, result in the dispositive in the end and are
said and unsaid there is
a nice example of an
American sociologist who once
researched the dispositive of the American
and came to the following conclusion is a good
American  definitely a young
married white urban
heterosexual protestant father
with college education permanent employment
good looks and success in sports
and every american
anyway because she is not a man falls
behind this this claim
behind this dispositif and
then feels partly or completely inferior  yes
or less value and we have now
said it is said and
unsaid because, for example, marriage
is legally defined in the church
there are rituals that are
said society wants to keep marriage as the
nucleus of society
at the same time defines  he in the
ideal image of the good american in which the
dispositive is also unspoken and
unsaid, for example that the now
heterosexual help of a service is
simply condemned, which you
might not say now, but
what is there and exerts coercion and that
is what he is currently focusing on  all my
books are small tool boxes and
asks our to use his analyzes and
his terms and
to continue working with these tools
himself, he also said you can
even short-circuit power systems with
his terms and he is
positive about this, the term dispositive is already
a good one  I understood and then
I had to work with the actual term
involuntarily. Of course I had a lot of
books with me on vacation and then my girlfriend
attacked me massively and criticized
I would be a bad vacationer if
I read today and not much
undertaken
and then I got over there  s
thinking about good service when you are
on vacation has quite a lot of constraints yes
laugh now but you have to
relax you have to be spontaneous you
have to open up in the moment and
to do that you also create structures
tourist structures you have to
move away from everyday life and the  work at a
place as far away as possible, so
possible the lonely
island. as a
landlocked country, you must have access to me and you must
definitely be far enough away from the airport
that you do not hear the many states
landing planes of the others, which
also follow positively, yes  and then
i asked myself where
does this this compulsion to
relax to spontaneity and to at the
moment come from and there i found von
kurras
i understand by dispositive a
formation whose main function at a
given historical point in time
consisted in one  emergency to
answer so this positive
always arise  r then when you have an emergency, there
are positive reactions to an
emergency and it was the same with the holiday it came about in the
empire i
researched it because
the workers there still had to work 12 14 hours it
was broken the goods
were removed they are sick
they were no longer able to
perform and then it was so
many socialist and
communist organizations organized themselves and then they gave in
to the unions and in
1903 the first
mandatory vacation was agreed, interestingly enough,
in the brewing industry and
yes, but of course it was in the
empire that an answer to an
emergency has been agreed, so to speak
, and by the way,
today the Federal Holidays Act I ca
n't even think I'm quoting it says
that Section 8 of the Federal Holidays Act
contradicts the recreational purpose, the
activities are to be avoided,
yes, because that is defined by  the
positive than  relaxing vacation yes and
i then tried to explain to my girlfriend
that i was the victim of a
dispositive it didn't work you
know it was my fault yes so you
see it doesn't always help
to recognize the positive so the structures are
still there yes so i would have me  now it's
better to get it but it helps
a bit if you look behind it
so i might be a nice
example of what it's quite simple the
cod liver oil i don't know there are
some my age here today
i had to use each as a child for quite a
long time  evening or morning
take cod liver oil terrible you
know and thanks to foucault i now know
that my mother didn't do it out of
spite but she was taken in by
a dispositive
when she knew that time that was the time of the
gods the time of now so
the doctors were great  not just a
son-in-law, but the promise of
health and eternal life, yes, so there went
the religious  ity was already back and the
doctors that was that they were little gods
you may remember the
advert, hundreds of poor little
students or something like that
wander around and brushed their teeth in the huge labs and then a guy like that came to
point out in the kindle had
said with his solid voice  the
only thing a scientist like
that does is help the child now and has the
toothpaste or the
dietary supplement or what you
need a foal yes and that is
positive it was just that only such
resources can ensure the healthy development of the child
and that is why
tens of thousands of mothers have it  children thanks to
this cod liver oil 1
monasteries well so it is now
maybe a bad example and you
see of course the photo has brought us much more
dramatic region more profound
examples but what we can
maybe remember what we
can take away is actually when
we should feel confronted with a forced situation
we think first
ken what is the dispositive
behind it secondly, when
was the dispositive set
up and for what reasons and thirdly the
positive are only deep truth
productions that can change again
and that means we can too according to
focus we are able and to  this
also poststructuralism is not
structural when we
recognize the structures we know that they
can change after we
ourselves can change
there are moments in life when the
question of whether you can think differently than you
think is essential
thank you very much
[applause]